So today I've titled The lecture for Today Confederation,
but in a sense of going to be talking about something larger than that.
And by the end of the lecture I'll be talking about the articles of
confederation.
I'll talk a little bit more about them on Thursday.
Um,
but as I mentioned last Thursday,
um,
last Thursday's lecture,
today's lecture and actually some of the few that are left but that are still to
come,
um,
are all in one way or another dealing with big questions that were left looming
after the fighting of the revolution had passed.
And we dealt with one of them on Thursday.
And that was the co the question of what would happen to American society.
And I looked at that in a very specific way,
but I was touching on that broader question,
which is,
okay,
so we've had a revolution,
what does that do?
And we sort of explored some things that did or didn't do.
Today I'm going to discuss a different big question leftover after the fighting
and actually going on even during the fighting.
And that is the question of what would happen to American governance.
How would independence from Great Britain actually affect the way that the
states individually functioned and the way that they were governed together and
it's not.
Obviously,
it's not just a question of little political technicalities because as people at
the time really knew,
aside from the obvious task of winning the war and gaining independence,
it was really political change.
It was the,
the shaping of new state governments and the creation of some kind of a new
national or American government that would most shape the real outcome of the
revolution as a whole as Jefferson put it right in the middle of the revolution.
In truth,
a new government is the whole object of the present controversy.
I love finding quotes from founders in which I think to myself,
I need a founder to say that politics is important.
Dick,
Dick.
Oh,
there's Thomas Jefferson.
No,
no government.
Just a whole object of the present controversy for Shit,
a bad government be instituted for us in the future.
It had been well to have accepted at first,
the bad one offered to us from beyond the water without the risk and expense of
the contest.
So basically as people at the time well knew it was in the creation of
governments in the states and one for all of the states that the revolution
ultimately would be lost or won.
We're going to hear this,
people talking about the seventies and eighties when they were a little alarmed.
It's what ha what is happening in the 17 is they're going to repeat that
sentiment like,
oh,
we thought we won and now we're going to lose because everything's going to fall
apart because of problems of government.
So on a really immediate level,
Americans knew that if they wanted to win the war in a broader sense,
they had to have effective governments
and obviously also in the longer term,
they needed effective governments to survive,
to prosper,
to last more than years.
It's fascinating when you look at letters between these people and the first
couple years under the constitution,
and they're really not convinced it's going to last more than a few years.
Nifty little experiment,
maybe it's not going to work.
So people understood government is the key.
So when the colonies declared independence in 1776 and these former colonies
became states they needed to create new state governments that would basically
write the royal government out of their form of governance and they,
they,
each state now needed to come up with a new way to govern itself or some
decision about how they were going to govern themselves.
So from roughly 1776 through the 70s,
80s,
the individual states,
and as we'll see in a little bit,
the continental Congress grappled with trying to figure out the best mode of
establishing new governments according to prevailing hopes and ideals.
And this whole period,
it was really a remarkable period of political experimentation.
As Benjamin Franklin said,
we are,
I think in the right road of the spirit of improvement for we are making
experiments,
right?
There was a man of science,
um,
basically in this whole period,
not just the revolution,
but a little before and certainly after fueled by the optimism of the revolution
and fueled by the whole spirit of the enlightenment.
This was an age of experiments in government and I always find when I'm trying
to get across what it felt like at that time,
how people thought about politics at that time.
I'm always sort of trying to figure out some great metaphors.
Some thing that I can say and I always come back to the same comparison,
which somehow at least in the last five or six years has always been true.
And that his innocence to get a feeling for what it felt like to think about
politics and experience politics in the late 18th century.
Think about how we now experience and think about technology.
Okay.
Cause basically they could announce tomorrow that apple was secretly coming up
with a device that allows you to see inside every home in America.
And we would go,
Ooh,
interesting.
But we would accept that then maybe that exists.
You know,
I mean there's,
on our part there's a sort of expectation that new technological innovations are
popping up all the time and they might have us doing our thinking things that we
never did before,
but communicating in new ways.
Technology I think for us is this realm where anything can happen and things are
happening all the time and we're adjusting and were excited and were interested
and that's where a lot of the innovation is now.
If people sort of trying to pour,
you know,
every app maker in America,
um,
people creating and innovating and devising and creating and that kind of spirit
transport that back to the late 18th century,
that's the way that people were feeling about government.
That was a period in which government was doing all of those things.
There were innovations,
there were,
it was experimental.
People didn't know what was going to happen.
They were challenging rules of government and sort of seeing what would happen.
It was particularly for people who are interested in politics.
It was a fascinating sort of wonderful time because all of these weird things
were happening and they were big,
literally constitutional things on a really big level and you can hear this kind
of excitement and a statement that John Adams wrote in 1776 and a pamphlet that
I'll be discussing in a few minutes and it's titled Thoughts on government and
Adams wrote,
you and I,
my dear friend,
had been sent into life at a time when the greatest log givers of antiquity
would have wished to have lived.
How few of the human race has ever enjoyed an opportunity of making an election
of government for themselves or their children.
People knew that what they were doing at that time was a big deal and they knew
it could affect enormous change.
So what I'm going to be talking about today in that spirit are these experiments
in government,
people experimenting and government,
and I'm going to talk about these kinds of experiments on two levels.
First I'll talk about state constitution making and how people were trying to
figure out what to do on a state level and then I'll discuss the process of
joining all of these states together into some kind of a confederation or as the
articles of confederation themselves,
put it a League of friendship.
That's how the government defines itself,
the articles,
they league a friendship,
but I want to start with state constitutions and the fact is,
although to us we think constitution is sort of the big looming thing that's
important in that period to people.
At the time,
certainly in the middle of the revolution,
it was really in the drafting of state constitutions that they really thought
the future of the American people was going to be decided even before the formal
declaration of independence in July of 1776 already,
people in the colonies had been giving some thought to the fact that they were
going to need new state constitutions because already things were unstable
sources of authority,
royal sources of authority.
We're not necessarily in place,
but it was unclear what was in place instead of them.
So people will already saw the need for some kind of new legitimate source of
authority.
And they began thinking,
okay,
well if we do end up being independent,
we need some kind of a new government.
So we better start talking about it now cause sooner or later,
probably sooner we're going to actually have to implement something.
So as early as the beginning of 1776 states began considering what they should
do about the unsettled state of governance in their own colonies.
And some colonies actually wrote to the continental Congress asking for advice
on what they should do about governance in their colony.
And there were some people in the continental congress that suggested,
well,
you guys should take some kind of an interim measure.
Things aren't sorted out yet with England.
We don't know what's going to happen,
sort of do something to tide you over until we figure out what's coming next.
But there were others who were more radical in their politics and the
continental congress who thought that the colonies actually should really
establish new political institutions.
Basically new constitutions,
more conservative congressmen argued that adopting new forms of government would
be as good as declaring independence even if independence hadn't been declared.
If the colony start creating their own constitutions,
these conservatives are arguing.
It's just as good as saying you're independent and it's going to make,
it's a reconciling with England even harder if you begin to do that.
Even so in May of 1776 the continental congress adopted a resolution saying that
colonial assemblies should adopt new governments and just as the Conservatives
in Congress argued certainly to John Adams and many others,
that resolution was what really was the instrument of American independence.
That's to Adams.
He saw that resolution is a really key turning point.
When the continental congress said to the colonies becoming states,
I think it's time that you should devise your own constitutions.
Now it's important to note the continental congress wasn't in the lead here.
What would happen is that colonies were asking them what to do and congress sort
of responded and figured out what it thought and then made a recommendation.
So states we're thinking about government before the continental congress
necessarily.
Did anything about it.
The first new constitution had already been drafted in New Hampshire in January
of 1776 making it the first written constitution drawn up by one of the colonies
without consultation with or approval of the crown or parliament.
So the states are all occupied with constitution making.
And that continued through 1777 now at first,
people in the congress were undecided about whether maybe it would be smart to
recommend to all of the colonies,
one model constitution.
Maybe they should come up with one model and sort of send it out and say,
here's what we think the best kind of government would be.
But after a brief debate,
the idea of went nowhere.
And that's basically for two reasons.
I think one of them is really obvious,
which is what is the likelihood that everybody in that Congress was going to
agree on what a model constitution ought to look like for all of the states?
Okay.
Not,
I mean,
on a,
on a purely pragmatic level,
that would be very hard to do.
But second and more important than that,
the Congress ultimately felt that people in each colony or each state should
really be adopting and devising their own governments that really suited their
own character,
their own habits,
their own specific needs,
local conditions.
So really it was the colonies themselves who were best suited.
It wasn't a smart idea to the congress ultimately for them to be imposing a
model,
anything since part of the purpose of the revolution was for people to devise
governments that suited them better and in making this suggestion that each
colony should be free to create a constitution that reflected their particular
values and habits.
The congress was pretty much acting in accordance with a prevailing belief at
the time that there was,
or certainly that there should be an intimate connection between the values of a
people,
between the habits of a people on the one hand and between their instruments of
government and systems of law.
On the other,
this general assumption,
one shapes the other one should shape the other,
and that's part of the assumption that the continental congress is acting on.
But just because Congress didn't mop,
didn't design a model constitution,
it doesn't mean that individual continental congressmen didn't begin thinking
about what ought to be happening in their own states back home.
And in fact,
so many continental congressmen became so obsessed with the idea of state
constitution making for their own states that some people feared that some of
the basic demands of the revolution were falling by the wayside because everyone
was saying,
oh well,
you know,
back home they're making up a constitution.
That's amazing.
Like I have some ideas about that.
I mean,
maybe I should even go back there.
Okay,
maybe not,
but I'll send them some ideas about what they ought to be doing.
So these delegates and the continental congress are extremely interested for
really obvious reasons in what's being devised back in their home colony,
their home state.
One result of this obsession with constitution making was this pamphlet I
mentioned a few moments ago,
which ends up being an important and influential pamphlet written by John Adams
that's titled Thoughts on government.
Now,
am's had long been really interested in constitutional issues and he actually
had something of a reputation for being someone who was pretty knowledgeable on
the subject.
So when these states began talking about new constitutions,
beginning at the very,
very end of 1775 going through 1776 several men from different states came to
him to ask his advice,
hey,
you're the guy who knows a lot about constitutions.
What do you think we ought to be doing,
Mr. Adams?
So Adam's so many people asked him that he wrote up what he called a sketch of
what a new constitution might look like and he gave the sketch out to a few
people.
Oh,
you want to know what I think a new constitution?
And it looked like,
here you go,
my best idea.
Well obviously if everyone's casting about like,
I dunno what to do,
what should I say?
And one guy pipes up and says,
I think this is a pretty good idea.
Not surprisingly,
other people went to Adams and said,
hey,
I'd like a copy of sketch too.
Like I,
I'd like to see what your model constitution looks like.
So by April of 17,
76,
Adams had turned this sketch into this pamphlet.
The full title of his pamphlet is one of these great 18th century titles,
thoughts on government applicable to the present state of the American colonies
in a letter from a gentleman to his friend.
We can call it thoughts on government now,
besides the obvious practical use of the pamphlet.
And I'm going to come back to some of the things he recommends in a minute.
Adams also intended it to be a response to the concluding section of Thomas
Paine's common sense published a few months earlier.
And you'll remember the wonderful opinion that John Adams registered on common
sense quote,
a poor,
ignorant,
malicious,
shortsighted,
crappy ulous mass.
Thank you John Adams.
Um,
so Adam's basically thought that that final section of common sense was
irresponsible and impractical.
It was giving ideas about forming a new government that didn't make sense.
And if you remember,
pain had said that there should be a unicameral a one house legislature for each
of the colonies and the that would be all of those would be subordinate to
unicameral legislature,
like the continental congress.
No level of government would have an independent executive.
So basically is Adams is thinking about it,
pain is just tossing off separation of powers and the balance of powers and
saying,
yeah,
we don't need to think about that.
We should be thinking about the people,
right?
We should be thinking about making a government responsive to people,
which is a nice idea.
But Adam's thought in reality there's no way that that's going to work.
Adams and others though they valued what pain had to say.
Obviously about independence did not appreciate that whole plan and in slots on
government.
Adam's argued that whatever the state's did with these new governments,
they should at least preserve the best of Anglo American traditions of
government and particularly separation of powers.
Adams really did not like the idea of having a one house assembly and having no
executive at all.
He argued that there was no way that that could work well at one house.
Legislature would never be effective.
We could never do anything.
Executive could never do anything judicial as he put it,
a one house legislature could not act as an executive power quote for want of
two essential properties,
secrecy and dispatch.
Okay.
That's what executives need to be.
No Congress will ever manage those two things.
He also said that a one house legislature couldn't be a judicial power because
it was too numerous,
too slow,
and too little skilled in the laws and just as bad to Adam's a unicameral
legislature was just unstable in and of itself.
As he put it,
it was liable to all the vices,
follies and frailties of an individual.
Subject to fits of humor starts with passion,
flights of enthusiasm,
partiality or prejudice,
and consequently productive of hasty results and absurd judgements.
I think that sounds like a quote from a guy who's really tired of being in
congresses.
It's like,
I know what Congress is.
Do this unicameral legislature,
bad idea.
He really preferred a bicameral legislature,
both houses of which would elect a governor.
The governor would have a veto over legislation,
could appoint judges and some other officers with the consent of the upper
house.
Judges would have tenure for life during good behavior and all officials apart
from judges would be elected annually to prevent an aristocratic ruling class
from rising up and to keep politicians humble because they'd have to go home
every year and get reelected and to Adams that would successfully keep
politicians humble.
Rotation in office would be something that would keep the right spirit of
government going.
Now it's hard to say how much direct influence thoughts on government had.
It's always very hard.
You always want to say,
wow,
these five states,
we're extremely influenced.
It's hard to say that,
but the fact is that most of the state constitutions ended up being in hailing
distance of what Adam suggested in that pamphlet and he did receive letters from
a number of friends saying,
well,
we actually,
that was helpful.
Thank you very much,
John Adams.
That was actually very helpful.
So we have this little moment in which John Adams must've been smiling cause
he's getting recognition.
Right.
Yay.
He's like,
I wrote a good pamphlet in there saying thank you.
Yay.
Poor John Adams.
Um,
okay.
So all this talking about new governments,
the fact is,
as I suggested when Adam says we should be preserving the best features of Anglo
American governance,
the state constitutions generally did preserve some basic features of Anglo
American governance.
So take for example by cameral legislature,
obviously resembling parliament's House of Commons and House of Lords.
Obviously American did not have Lords and Commons in quite the same way,
but the idea remained you had two houses and you had different sets of people in
the two.
Although it was not entirely clear what that meant in the American example,
and this was actually a source of confusion,
right?
When the constitution first starts with this new by camera legislature,
people aren't sure if the Senate is kind of like a House of Lords,
meaning that the people in the Senate or sort of higher up than the
representatives,
do they have like special privileges?
Should there be?
Should they get a higher salary or they like special people in comparison to the
house?
Should we really be making that kind of difference between the House and the
Senate?
And you can see this throughout this period.
You can see it in somewhat ridiculous ways,
but you can see how people were so focused on it.
And one example of this is um,
from 1790,
so the one year of government and the Senate wrote some kind of a bill and they
included I suppose,
names of people who had drafted the bill and before the names of the people,
they put the honorable at the honorable miss years,
blah,
blah.
And they sent this to the house.
The House got this bill.
They didn't even look at the content of the bill.
They just looked at the bill.
Why are the senators calling themselves the honorable?
We don't like that.
What's it suggesting about who they are?
I think they're better than us.
No,
they're not better than us.
So the house before it votes on the content of the bill votes to cut those two
words out.
Right.
That's not going to be on the document.
None of this honorable stuff.
Then they pass it and it goes back to the Senate and the Senate passes another
amendment in which they take their names off the document because they don't
want them printed without the honorable attached to them.
Okay.
Seemingly little trivial petty thing,
but that clearly two parts of the legislature we're focused on and there was
even a letter from Madison and I can't remember who he's writing to and he says,
this seems trivial,
but it really isn't because it's getting down to these kind of basic questions
of exactly what is the house and what is the Senate and what's their
relationship to the House of Lords,
the House of Commons.
So a by camera legislature is one tradition that Americans held onto,
generally speaking,
and I'm going to come back to an exception,
a second traditional assumption that was represented in the new state
constitution is concerned the need for property requirements for voting and for
holding elected office and the reasoning they're being men who owned property.
We're independent men so they could vote for themselves as they thought rather
than being dependent on someone else and thus maybe having to vote in a way that
somebody else wanted them to vote.
And likewise it was thought that if you had literally financial investment in a
community,
you are the people best qualified to affect that community through elections.
So though the revolution would inspire many states to reduce the level of the
property requirement for voting,
the fact is those kinds of restrictions remain in place.
And on average in the new state constitutions roughly there was an increase of
15% in the number of adult white males voting,
which in a sense compared I suppose with England maybe seems a little bit of
somewhat substantial as not revolutionary in scope.
So that was held onto as well as something that people felt comfortable with.
That was a precedent,
a tradition that made sense to them.
Now there were other ways in which these constitution,
the state constitution,
rather than reflecting traditions,
Anglo American traditions instead more obviously reflected the immediate impact
of the revolution.
And the first and most obvious example of that is the simple fact that they're
writing constitutions,
right?
Americans were revealing their recognition of what they believe to be the
instability and lack of security in unwritten constitutions.
As they looked at Great Britain,
they thought,
we don't like that system.
Pretty much.
We want everything in writing.
We want it all on paper.
Americans wanted to fix the principles of their new governments in writing in a
form that was distinct from and superior to mere legal statutes.
You can also see the immediate impact of the revolution in the three main ideas
that were at the core of most of the state constitutions.
Three sort of basic ideas.
Number one,
most of these constitutions were premised on the idea that they had to be
grounded on natural rights and you can really see this belief reflected in the
declarations of rights that were appended to most state constitutions.
And again,
there is a lot that's traditional in these declarations of rights because a lot
of the rights that are being declared in these declarations are traditional
English rights,
but they're being put in on paper in these documents and then attached to these
sort of constitutional statements,
creating whatever these new states we're going to be
most of these declarations of rights specified things like the right of trial by
jury,
right?
They thought back to the revolution.
They remembered those vice admiralty courts not popular,
so now they're like,
okay,
we want the right of trial by jury.
We want the right not to be deprived of life,
liberty and property through the protection of due process of law,
freedom of speech,
freedom of the press and in some states like Virginia,
freedom of religion,
again,
rights that are familiar to us,
rights that they're putting down on paper and attaching to constitutions at this
moment in time.
So declarations of rights were shared by constitutions.
This sort of idea that there are these natural rights that need to be written
down and memorialized.
One of the things that all of the state constitutions generally share.
The other two main ideas that were at the core of these constitutions are
related.
So these are the last two ideas are most constitutions declared that
representation is based on consent.
Again,
obviously coming right out of the revolution,
consent is important in the process of representation.
And then the third and last basic idea related to that is,
and maybe it's the most central one of all sovereignty rests with the people.
The people are sovereign
as the Virginia Constitution declared and and a lot of the other states in one
way or another rephrased it,
but said something like it all power is vested in and consequently derived from
the people that the magistrates are their trustees and servants and at all times
amenable to them.
The main question about this was as John Allen's put it at the time,
to what extent should we carry this principles like nice idea.
What does that exactly mean?
How's it going to actually boil down into what people are actually doing?
How beholden should the government be to the people?
And this varied in different states depending on a number of different kinds of
factors.
One dramatic way in which you could really see the sovereignty of the people
being emphasized in these new state constitutions is through the way in which
they curbed executive power.
They curved the power of state governors.
They made state governors less important.
They usually made the lower house of their legislature is more important.
They often made the upper house of their legislatures less important.
They're really trying to limit power to curb power.
Again,
that's obviously really connected to what they had just experienced in the
revolution,
which felt to them like this sort of monarchical unlimited power that they had
no control over.
So they're really worried about executive power,
fear of a concentration of power,
fear of executive power,
like the power of the monarch that they had just,
or at least in the process of breaking away from.
So as I said,
almost every new state constitution increase the power of the lower house,
decreased the power of the governor,
decreased the power of the upper house of their legislatures.
And as we'll see in a moment,
the national government government that ends up being created under the articles
of confederation follows the same general pattern.
They just eliminate executive and they don't have a judicial branch either.
So basically everyone's really scared of executive power of,
of centralized power at this point.
Okay.
So summing up what I've just been discussing,
in essence,
most new state constitutions shared a few basic institutional features.
They had a bike camera,
legislature,
they had a weak executive,
they had rotation in office,
they had,
um,
as far as principals go that a lot of them at least had declarations of rights.
The idea that representation should be based on consent,
that the government rests on the people,
that the people are sovereign.
A somewhat broader electorate voting in annual elections.
Now that said,
the most extreme constitutional revisions actually took place in Pennsylvania
and Pennsylvania is really where the constitution ultimately reflected the most
radical impulses of the revolution.
The new Pennsylvania Constitution had no property requirements for voting.
It had a one house legislature and it has some special features that clearly to
the people who were devising that constitution were aimed at making the
government as responsible to popular consent as possible.
So for example,
this is kind of wild to me.
Imagine how many laws would actually pass if this is the case for a lot to
become a law in Pennsylvania,
uh,
Bill had to be passed in two consecutive sessions of the legislature.
So a bill had to be passed twice.
So,
and between those two sessions,
the politicians who were passing the bill had to go home and explain it to their
constituents.
So you would pass a law.
These got the representatives would go to their constituents and explain why
they liked it and then they'd have to go back and pass it again.
Right.
Obviously the idea of being,
okay,
these people are really beholden to their constituents and nothing's going to
happen unless the constituents really approve of it.
The Pennsylvania Constitution also created this nifty little sort of body called
the council of sensors.
And this council of sensors was kind of like a big grand jury.
It would be elected every seven years.
And the job of the council of sensors was to evaluate all aspects of government
action.
So basically they create this little body and the job of it is to just police
government and make sure that everything is above board and operating in the way
it's supposed to be operating.
So you can really see in comparison with what I was just saying about the sort
of generality of the state constitutions.
Pennsylvania really has an extreme reaction to the experience of the revolution
against what the colonists perceived to be as tyranny.
So in a sense,
if you,
if you think of ideas about government as being kind of a pendulum and on one
end you've got sort of British monarchical centralized power in Pennsylvania.
Boy that pendulum went way over onto the other side.
Like we don't want any centralized executive power.
We're just going to be over here sort of experimenting with this interesting
government that we haven't ever had one legged before.
And as we'll see as we look at what happens over the next 10 15,
17 years,
the constitution in a way represents a midpoint between these two ends of the
spectrum.
One last point I want to,
um,
discuss about state constitutions before we get into the articles.
Um,
while all of the state constitution revision was taking place,
there were actually two states that we're not taking part in in it,
not out of protest,
but because their colonial charters actually had in a sense been more radical
than the other colonies to begin with.
And of course they are Connecticut and Rhode Island Continuing Theme Connecticut
and Rhode Island,
their colonial charters had basically made them self governing already in on a
certain level so they didn't have to do dramatic changes to make them into state
constitutions.
So they basically,
Rhode Island and Connecticut basically preserved their colonial charters is
constitutions and didn't really change them until into the 19th century.
Okay.
That gets us out of the world of state constitutions and into the world of
creating some kind of government for the new union of American States.
And that's ends up being the articles of confederation.
Now on July 12th,
1776 just after they had declared independence,
the continental congress also was trying to create some kind of a proposal for a
new national government.
And between 1776 and 1777 the continental congress drafted the articles of
confederation
and the articles are the document that literally created the United States of
America.
They literally gave that name to the United States of America.
But it's important that to know that they actually meant that really literally,
I mean,
and we don't,
we sort of don't think of what that phrase means,
but it was meant really literally in the context of what I'm talking about now.
What that said was this was not one consolidated nation.
This was United States.
What the article is created at United some states together.
That's what that phrase literally meant.
As John Adams explained later,
they never thought of consolidating this vast continent under one national
government,
but instead erected a confederacy of states,
each of which must have a separate government.
So when 13 free and independent states had defeated England and now had to
figure out how to come together,
they were not thinking of one big unified republic at this point.
They really definitely we're not.
And that's the articles of confederation went along with that thinking it did
not create one unified government.
It did not bond people together in anything other than a loose league.
The articles created a loose league of individual Republican governments.
Now,
if as the founding generation assumed absolute power corrupts absolutely than
the articles of confederation was a very virtuous form of government.
Because under the articles,
the Confederation Congress had almost no power to enforce.
It's will at all.
The newly created confederation was almost more of a United Nations than a
central governing institution.
As the articles themselves stated,
they were intended to create quote a from League of friendship for their common
defense,
the security of their liberties and their mutual and general welfare.
The articles were basically a pact between 13 sovereign states,
which agreed that certain powers would be delegated to this new central
government for very specific purposes.
But these 13 sovereign states retained all powers,
not expressly delegated by them in the articles.
So under the articles,
the national government consisted of a one chamber,
National Congress elected by the state legislatures.
Each state had one vote.
Congress could request funds from the states,
but it could not enact a tax of its own without every state's approval.
Again,
how likely is that to happen?
So it could not really make its own taxes.
It could not regulate interstate commerce between the states.
The article did not provide for any kind of an executive branch or any kind of
an executive character at all.
Instead,
congressional committees oversaw anything having to do with finance or diplomacy
or military affairs.
There was no judicial system by which this new national government could compel
allegiance to its laws.
So basically,
as far as the powers of Congress were concerned,
the confederation congress was kind of feeling the place of the imperial system.
It could regulate foreign affairs,
it could declare war with foreign countries,
it could negotiate peace treaties,
it could fix standards for weights and measures.
It could manage Indian affairs.
It could borrow money,
although it couldn't really tax.
Basically the Confederation Congress had power over war and foreign affairs and
the states maintained control over what they called internal policing.
Now it's important to realize that in the context of the time when they were
created,
the articles of confederation actually make perfect sense.
I think it's really easy,
and I'll talk a little bit more about this on Thursday.
I think it's really easy to look at the articles and say,
Huh,
what were they thinking?
How did that make sense?
Let's create a government and give it no power go.
Yeah,
so I think,
I think the articles get a bum rap basically in the long view of history and I
think it's important to realize at that moment in time they made perfect sense
given the experience of the revolution and what people had just experienced in
the realm of government.
Basically the articles denied to this new government,
the very powers and violations that they had seen at the heart of the
revolution.
So the Congress can't tax,
the Congress can't overrule local laws.
The congress can't alter a state constitution.
It can't interfere with state judicial proceedings.
All of these things are things that we saw in past weeks happening during the
course of the revolution inflicted by the British.
So this is a really,
I mean,
again and again,
when people are creating constitutions,
they learn a lesson and then they act based on that lesson that they learned.
And Then Bay,
they look at this new thing they created and go,
okay,
new lesson learned.
Let's make another government because we didn't like that one so much.
But you can actually see people experiencing someone thinking about what that
means and then creating a government based on those immediate lessons.
That's what we see here with the articles of confederation.
And then to avoid an entrenched elite,
we don't want any kind of a little aristocracy coming up in America.
The articles did establish rotation in office.
So you could not be in office more than three of every six years.
You couldn't be president of Congress more than one in any three years.
And any delicate could be instantly recalled by his home state.
Okay,
so there are,
we see this,
this weak central government.
Lots of things that can't do.
There were very,
very few things that the states were restricted from doing under this new
compact,
but there were a couple of things that the states were not supposed to do.
And you'll hear they're not exactly Dyer restrictions.
Okay.
So no state could enter into an alliance or treaty with a foreign nation without
the consent of Congress.
So New Jersey cannot make a treaty with France.
Okay?
They need to go through congress.
No,
two or more states could enter into a confederation without the consent of
Congress.
Okay?
Think about that one.
So New England can't break away and form its own confederation without least
checking with us first.
Would you allow us to break off and form our own confederation?
No.
I,
that would've been an interesting little game.
No.
Well,
we'll try to stop us,
but at least it's saying states are not supposed to form their own little mini
confederations states.
We're not to keep warships or troops in peacetime unless Congress deemed it
necessary for defense states.
We're not supposed to declare war without consent of Congress.
That's nice.
Except where sudden invasion admitted have no delay.
Okay?
Those are the restraints,
right?
Ooh,
those are not dire restraints.
Don't don't like make war with another country all by yourself.
Don't break away from the articles from the League of friendship and form your
own little country.
Don't make a treaty with a foreign nation all by yourself.
Those are the restrictions on the states.
Obviously none of these restraints placed too serious a check on the sovereignty
of the states under this compact.
So essentially the articles of confederation were designed so that the new
nation's central government would not infringe on the states.
As I said before,
it would kind of fill the hole where the the British imperial system had been
before.
Have a very,
very limited sphere of actions,
not really have a power of enforcement and leave everything that wasn't
specified to the states to control on their own.
Now,
this is a document that's being drafted in the middle of a revolution and what
we're going to see over the course of the next few lectures is that once
revolutions end,
and this,
remember we started the course by talking about how the colonies came together
basically when they needed to defend themselves.
And then as soon as I didn't need to defend themselves,
they went boom and sort of parted.
Okay,
we had this revolution and the states,
the colonies,
they come together,
they unite,
they fight together,
and then the war ends.
So guess what the 1780 [inaudible] is going to look like.
Okay.
It's going to look like just what you think it will look like.
The states basically all turn their back on each other and say,
well,
that was nice.
Now we're going to do our own thing.
Thank you very much.
So the articles is drafted in a time when there's this cooperation going on
between the states.
What we're going to see in the next two lectures,
um,
is what happens when these articles actually go into effect.
What do the 70s and eighties look like?
And that's going to take us on the road to new lessons being learned and yet
another government think about,
think about the pace at which governments are being created in this period.
It gets back to where I started at the beginning of this lecture.
They're just,
hey,
we need a new government.
Let's make one now.
Okay,
how do you like that one?
I Dunno,
we need to revise it there.
Also revising these governments throughout this period that's also got to be a
little unsettling.
You know,
it's part of why in this period people tend to get very upset or scared.
Something goes a little wrong and they think it's the end of the government.
Well,
if it's only two years old,
you know,
maybe it will collapse.
And if these are the guys who actually made the government,
then they kind of have a good reason for thinking that it could fall apart.
They were there when they put it together,
maybe it's actually going to collapse.
So that's actually,
and we're gonna see that,
particularly in the seventies and eighties,
and then the 1790,
if you won't be talking so much about the 1790 [inaudible] um,
if you want to take my early national America course,
that will start right where this one drops off actually,
and takes us into the 1790s.
But you can see that spirit in the 17 nine [inaudible] of people saying,
wow,
we've been creating a lot of governments.
You think this one's going to stick around?
I don't know.
I hope so.
Maybe it'll last for five years.
That'll be exciting.
So,
okay,
I will stop there on Thursday.
We will look at what happened when the articles go into effect.